abby's with us in lexington kentucky hi
abby welcome to the ramsay show
hey how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so my husband and i are awaiting the
arrival of our
first baby any day now
anything what is it um it's a boy
and we have wonderful and supportive
families who are
you know wanting to
help invest for this baby and so um
they brought up the idea someone
mentioned to them that they
like are interested in purchasing a life
insurance policy for the baby once
they're born
and my husband and i don't particularly
feel like that's the best
idea but we don't know how to articulate
why
or even maybe what we would prefer
instead we do work with investment
professionals for our you know our
investing that we
do um for retirement
and so i guess what would be the best
option to suggest you know should we set
up a 529
should we set up a roth um how can they
can
what would be easiest for them to just
contribute to when they want to
what what would you suggest there's
nothing as stupid as a brand new
grandparent
i know i have lived it i
am that guy we want to do i mean this
you wouldn't believe the crap i bought
for
babies on their first christmas stuff
they can't use till they're 16.
i filled up the whole living room my
daughters were so disgusted with me
they're like you're keeping this at your
house i'm not taking this home well it
doesn't even make your kid can't drive
until he's 16 but you bought him too
yeah oh yeah that they're sweet
they're sweet but they're just being
dumb you're right how do you
how do you always explain the life
insurance policy it's to replace income
right if someone was to pass whoever's
dependent on that person's income this
baby is no one dependent
on him well and what's happened is some
stupid life insurance agent got a hold
of them and told him it was a way to
invest for college and let me tell you
where they're going to college if they
do it off a life insurance policy
they're not going to college
so um it's just a horrible investment
they're sweet but they're just doing it
wrong
so we just need to we just need to guide
them a little bit here and be
and give them a lot of grace because
truthfully they're so excited their
brains aren't working
yeah so yeah i i think you're right i
think you go to your investment
professional and you set up a 529
and you go hey guys any of you that are
wanting to invest in their future
we would consider it an honor if you
would contribute to the 529 yeah for
college
and hint hint the insurance is a stupid
idea
if they go buy it anyway you know
it's just one of those things a stupid
grandparent did that where they wasted
their money i mean
but it's a it you know but you don't
just advice
from the other side of the aisle here
because i'm on the other side of this is
you're probably not going to keep them
from doing all the stupid things you
want them to not do
it's just first i'm curious abby did
they ask you
if you wanted that or are they saying
they're going to do that
no they had just mentioned that oh we
heard this is a good idea we thought
about doing it
we're going to talk to our intern it's
not a hill
yeah it's not a hill worth dying on just
say i would just do a drive-by on it at
some point
and you don't have to do it immediately
but at some point go hey you guys
mentioned that life insurance thing
we don't do investing in life insurance
at our place we do it in mutual funds
and so we've got a 529 set up and if you
put it in there
we would that would be the way we would
prefer you do it and
but if they do it anyway don't get all
mad about it it's just them being stupid
yeah
that's what we figured it's no skin off
our teeth either way but just
if you know if there was a better way to
suggest
how would you how would you suggest it
from from her side when they mean
you've had to handle in-laws i i have
and i think if you just
it's not so much no to this idea as it
is hey we really like this idea so focus
on the yes focus on the the positive
keep it positive
but what i would find appealing what i
would think the grandparents would find
appealing about the 529
is it's something so tangible you're
investing in their future their college
their education
and just say hey like we want to start
investing early in saving for their
college education for his college
education
if you want to do that that'd be really
cool that you could participate in
investing in his future in that way when
he's 18 he's going to get to go to
school because this money we start to
paint this picture and then he'll be
able to point back and go you know
grandma and grandpa were the ones who
helped us fund this that's right you're
going to college because of grandma and
grandpa
and you know they get the credit and
stuff or part of the credit or however
all that kind of thing so i just keep it
positive focus on what you do want them
to do not what you don't want them to do
and maybe they'll
they'll move in that direction yeah
because here's what's going to happen
after there's six or seven grandkids
running around
um they're going to get bored with all
this
the novelty wears off they're not well
they're not going to be as big a problem
because they're going to be there
their sugar is going to be dialed down a
little bit so
like i'm a lot more chill with number
seven than i was with number one right i
mean i had to have
yeah i was i was the problem papa dave
with number one
how do we raid them in i told um the
team today dave during one of our shoots
my
my dad one of the ways that he shows
love he thinks the larger the present
physically larger the more love i'm like
dad i don't have any more room in my
house
get it out too much stuff large plastic
things with motors in them for boys yes
i'm like no more no more six of those
cars if one is good
six is better yes oh my gosh
absolutely yeah so funny yeah you do get
uh it's that way with kids i mean
the first one went off to college we
cried and the second one we cried for 10
minutes the third one we appointed
colleges that go that way
and so you know it's just like rachel
talks about that she's still scarred by
it you know
yeah she's scared by it she's got a lot
of scars
but uh so yeah it's uh
choose your battles because they're not
going to always be there yep
the battles aren't going to always be
there i mean yep um and and so
um it's a bigger deal to you right now
than it will be with the third kid
it's a bigger deal to them right now
than it will be with the seventh
grandkid
well because the emotions do you just
kind of calm down a little bit totally
and i think how you approach
discussions totally are different if the
decision doesn't directly affect you
like if you're talking about something
like
they want to move next door to you
because they want to take care of the
kids every day like that affects you
if they get a life insurance policy on
the baby that doesn't affect you in a
real practical day-to-day way
yeah and so that changes how you
approach it too yeah you can ignore the
stupidity because it's doing no damage
yeah it's not really their bank account
yeah yeah that's exactly right but
i think a good thing is just a way to
redirect it but i always think of my
granny gave us uh
uh savings bonds which suck i mean
horrible rate of return like two percent
or something that's just what she wanted
to do and she gave us a 50 or 100
savings bond for each kid every
christmas for chris for college
i would instantly cash them out and put
them in mutual funds because they suck
yeah
you know but i always lied to her i mean
no i told her the truth sort of but i
mean she would say how's those savings
bonds doing i see they're great granny
they're getting their
rate returned because after i cashed
them out and put them in a mutual fund
they are great but so that was partially
true but yeah i got rid of them as soon
as i could but
but she was doing a nice thing the wrong
way or the least efficient way
and so you know we just had to redirect
because there was no
talking to her about it she was a
savings bond generation
that was the thing you know that's uh
put all our money in the cds and all the
kids money and savings bonds and it's um
because we're children of the depression
all that stuff there you go